Rajan is now are the shadow foreign
secretary for labour Hillary bend and
surgery increasingly secretary-general
of the European Parliament between 1997
2007 he joins us on the line Henry been
we've now got this referendum bill
published by the government does labour
have any problems with it well we're
going to vote for the bill when it's
debated in the house of commons
circumstances have changed there is now
going to be a referendum we need to get
on and have the debate in this country
about our future place in Europe and
will be arguing very strongly in that
referendum because of jobs and
investment and security and Britain's
influence in the world that Britain
should remain a member of the European
Union but the decision is now going to
be made by the British people sir Julian
how does the fact that a referendum is
going to happen change the bargaining
positions I suppose we have to call it
now of the other members of the EU well
first of all I mean I think that it was
widely assumed that there was a strong
chance of having a referendum even
before the election secondly I think
that what people are really interested
in is to know precisely what sort of
changes that the government is really is
looking for in detail is the government
prepared to work constructively with the
27 other member states whose agreement
would be required for any changes that
are made they'll be interested to see
how realistic some of the proposals are
and they'll also want to know that if if
the government is successful in getting
some of its aims through will the
government on the David Cameron really
campaign strongly for Britain to remain
within the European Union how many
members of the European Union are there
other than Britain who might think it's
in their interests actually to see the
back of the Troublesome Brits I think a
lot of people get irritated from time to
time with the Brits but actually the
vast majority of member states and I
can't think of a single member state
which actively wants Britain to leave
the question is how far would they be
prepared to go to meet Britain's
concerns and also what precisely are the
changes that Britain is seeking are they
seeking to
have changed completely the nature of
the European Union do they accept that
actually treaty change is a very
cumbersome and difficult mechanism for
achieving change within the European
Union are they prepared to work for
compromise and then are they prepared to
back up what they have negotiated I mean
everybody's out of sight labour doesn't
only back now the idea of a referendum
it also backs the need for change what
are the changes you want to see yes we
do think that there needs to be changed
and it's a view shared by a number of
other European countries look the world
changes in the European Union needs to
change the result we are looking for
things like benefits people having to
contribute first before they take out
longer transitional controls if there's
any further enlargement of the European
Union we've proposed the red card system
which would build on the yellow card
that we helped to negotiate when we're
in government so that if a number of
national parliaments said where we don't
like this proposal then it would be
taken off the table but the point about
reforming in Europe and I think Julie
makes a very important point is that
it's not about what one government asks
for at one moment in time backed up by a
referendum don't forget David Cameron
didn't originally want this referendum
he only decided to go for it to deal
with the problems he's got in the
Conservative Party it is very
reminiscent to 40 years ago when Howard
Wilson did exactly the saying when labor
was in government then and we had the
first referendum think of them one of
the most significant changes we've seen
in Europe over the last 30 years the
decline in the proportion of the budget
spent on the Common Agricultural Policy
from what over seventy percent to around
thirty percent now that shows that very
significant change is possible in Europe
but to do it you have to make the
argument win friends influence and
that's exactly what the Prime Minister
is going to be discovering on his tour
around the capitals of Europe well see
Julian they could be some potential
advantages in voting no couldn't there
and actually coming out of the European
Union well that isn't the view of the
vast majority of people in business it
isn't the view of mantra the vast
majority of people in trade unions or in
associations etc it is the view of a
vocal currently a minority but they
haven't actually stipulated an
alternative plan alternative model which
really works and the idea that
you can be a part of the internal market
except all the rules but forfeit the
right to change the rules of the
internal market seems to me to be
curious politics but we know now that
this issue one of the differences from
the 70s it's closely connected to
migration the number of people in this
country and it seems impossible to
actually change migration by European
people here without coming out of the EU
isn't it well as far as any future
migration is concerned the longer
transitional controls in and at the end
it happens well it depends on which
countries we're talking about and the
basis on which they were emitted because
an individual member state could say
well we won't agree to that further
member state coming and unless we can
determine the length of the transitional
controls frankly for as long as we like
so that that is one option that is
available to member states currently in
those negotiations in the future I think
the issue in Britain is that what we
know that migration has been good
overall economically the migrants make a
net contribution they're paying taxes
that are helping to pay for the health
service some of them are working a mail
service and doing operations and
providing very important sources of
labor but the the benefits are not being
shared equally people are concerned
about depression of some wage rates
there's a sea with interest the
government has adopted one of our
proposals that they're going to make it
illegal for employment agencies to
advertise exclusively in other European
countries that's not right it's and
that's why we said it should change and
and it's about dealing with those
concerns that people have got okay we're
going to have really there thank you
both very much